today we are in Long Beach and we are
heading on a boat and heading out to
Catalina I'm so excited because we're
here with a Sony Alpha crew and we're
all testing out the brand-new 860 400
the camera actually comes out in
February if you guys want to see my
review that I did of it previously I
will put a link in the description
here's Jenna hello what's up today I'm
shooting in 24 frames a second I don't
know how I feel about it this is a test
for me it's a big day so come along with
the adventure I have no idea what's
gonna happen today but there's a bunch
of other youtubers here I feel like I
fell into some weird alternate reality
where everyone's logging and flowing
themselves except I just realized it's a
reality
everybody is vlogging and moving himself
[Music]
you know me you know me now one is never
enough okay yeah I look like I'm dressed
for the winter I've got a scarf another
jacket
another winter jacket it's gonna be cool
on that island I don't think anybody
else is step one we made it to the
island step two get the golf cart
look at this dog Ling basketball
[Applause]
[Music]
I've seen here I'll be your driver for
today please rate me five stars before
no less than three he just gave me
instructions and I don't remember what
he said reminder guys if your zip line
or Arial you're gonna go out around the
plasma and then just kind of Berg around
on that follow the line follow the eye
we're in the lead so you're like we're
leading this whole charge I think I'm
gonna go to a cafe and get a coffee
they're cloners yes
[Music]
egg and cheese would you get me Wow
the Sun is setting very very soon but
Jenna called it and I was watching her
stuff and she said they have breakfast
all day and all you gotta get it Oh got
it got it
[Music]
I just had a quick little interval shot
as here that's probably one of my
favorite features on the a 6400 farooq
is back there I phoned oh hello let me
zoom in on you these are so slow golf
carts are regulated with speed it's
quite tragic this is slow hit the brakes
even this faster I did
why are you here I don't know oh this is
not like a raptor so you've been driving
around the island and we're getting
elected sunset
[Music]
so while Jenna and I were out on our
go-kart excursion I thought about you I
said crazy sport I was like I wonder if
he's birds only shorts but look at these
shows search for super sure I get a good
luck I'm really cold still he's
virtually had a blast it was incredible
so what everyone's favorite thing about
a 600 nerdy to say color science I
really love the way that the colors look
on this camera it's much better than the
a 6300 which is the camera that I'm used
to so having really good skin tones is a
huge upgrade not today but it is the
6500 better than the 6300 cheers Cheers
oh that autofocus look at that one the
tracking isn't tracking your face now so
it didn't does my hair look good I see
I'm for you I'm 12
what is this wait what that's an
Internet I'm 12 what is this I don't get
it I'm so not cool I've never seen I
mean that's like I'm 12 and what is this
just see yo well that's my blog god
these guys are making fun of me I hope
you guys enjoyed the video I'm not even
sure what I feel we did a lot of things
very very quickly
I've fun I want to come back here and do
that aerial thing it's like climbing the
choice
[Music]